if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helix sleep.com
pacman
the covet pandemic in the united states
is becoming more and more politically
red um a year ago we wondered would this
happen and then six months ago we said
this will probably happen and then three
months ago we said the data is showing
that this is starting to actually happen
but now it's not only completely
undeniable the degree to which in the
united states
covid has become a republican killer a
republican virus disproportionately
is quite stunning and overwhelmingly the
coveted deaths are happening
in counties that donald trump won
and presumably logically overwhelmingly
it is trump voters who are dying from
covid at much higher rates than biden
voters now would it be enough to
influence an election
at a congressional district level
in a state
federally
really still a question mark in terms of
the math but as we've looked at with
hypothetical numbers from florida a few
months ago
if this continues to be
disproportionately a virus that kills
republicans in the united states because
republicans are disproportionately
unvaccinated it actually could come to
make a difference for example in
something like the florida gubernatorial
election it's a bit of a stretch but
it's possible but let's look at the
numbers that we have now first the new
york times has a really good piece on
this
which shows how the partisan gap has
grown and grown and grown since january
1st
where it was only slightly more likely
in january that the cova deaths were in
the trump counties rather than the biden
counties now remember this is a chart of
coveted death rates
so for people saying well there's more
people or fewer people no no this is the
rate per 100 000 people in january
there was a slightly higher rate of
death in trump voting counties than
biden counties
that gap has spread and spread starting
around mid-september it is increased
dramatically to the point where now as
you can see here the cumulative death
rate
is under 200 deaths per hundred thousand
people in biden counties and it is
rapidly approaching 300 deaths per 100
000 people in trump counties that is a
huge huge difference now there have been
many
attempts i guess i would call them
by various right wingers of different
stripes to explain this difference away
by saying well the difference is weather
in those places or
the difference is age in these places in
trump versus biden counties but when you
examine the data
it's not supported by fact
and as it's pointed out in the new york
times article about these numbers if the
difference was due to weather or age we
would have seen that partisan split last
year but instead
we are seeing a dramatic increase in
that partisan split over the last few
months
what we are seeing is a shift
in what determines who is most likely to
die and i'll tell you what i mean by
that at the start of the pandemic we've
talked about this now we've said this
before
the deaths were most likely to be
happening in the places that had we
would call it the misfortune of being
early infection sites because
of the direct flights to and from the
early infected regions of china and some
countries in europe like italy so you
had new york
new york new jersey you had boston with
that early conference and many non-stop
flights to asia for example and a few
other spots that early that was what
indicated what who was getting hit the
hardest we now have a very different
situation we now know about how the
virus spreads we now have it everywhere
so to speak
and we now have vaccination widely
available
and now
the biggest distinguishing factor
between the trump counties and the biden
counties is the level of vaccination
40 percent of republican adults are not
vaccinated only 10 percent of democratic
registered adults are unvaccinated that
is why the coveted deaths are
concentrated not in major metropolitan
areas but rather on a rate basis
remember we're talking about a rate of
death
the the the deaths are increasingly
concentrated where conservatives tend to
live more suburban and rural areas
because they have a far lower rate of
vaccination now it doesn't just apply to
deaths
if you look at cases we are seeing
a big partisan gap there as well it was
biggest in august and now thanks to the
national decline in covet cases although
the last 10 days make us wonder whether
cases are going to go back up we now see
still a partisan gap on cases but a
slightly smaller one than we had in
august so covid is getting more and more
politically red it's not republic it's
not um a surprising thing that we are
seeing this increasingly ravage
republicans at this point in time and
there's a good chance i mean even when
we say look at the death rate in this
biden county
it stands to reason that because
republicans are disproportionately
unvaccinated that even in biden counties
the deaths happening there skew towards
the republican party so in the every
country is different in the united
states we increasingly are seeing this
as a republican pandemic does it mean
liberals can't die of course not the the
virus doesn't discriminate on the basis
of politics however
vaccination
is the greatest indicator as to where we
are seeing the virus kill more versus
fewer people and it is republicans who
are disproportionately unvaccinated so
we're going to keep following these
numbers but it is a trend we expected
it's the trend we started to see and the
degree to which we are now seeing it is
quite stunning do republicans care even
if they don't care about the people that
are dying maybe they don't maybe they do
i don't know you'd have to ask them
um
at some point don't you think that they
would wake up and say hey this is this
is killing our voters more than it is
killing their voters and merely from the
perspective of like a pragmatic um uh
election strategy at some point you
would imagine they would start saying
hey you know i mean like this isn't good
maybe we should go and get ourselves
vaccinated hey this is something very
interesting
um
i want to be really careful about what i
say because i want to protect people's
privacy here
a fox news executive has leaked some
documents to me about fox news's vaccine
policy and vaccine reporting
requirements
and
fox news is really really strict even
though on air fox news has made a huge
deal out of attacking vaccine
requirements and protocols and mandates
or whatever you call them and even
though fox hosts on air have said we
don't have a mandate here we have a
protocol even though it's a stricter
protocol than the one outlined by joe
biden um they behind the scenes
are
really taking this seriously and fox
news has an insanely high vaccination
rate why because vaccine requirements
work as we've said before so we've gone
at it we've been asked by this fox
executive who's sick of what's going on
there this is stunning stuff we've been
asked by them
to remove any personally identifying
information which i have done okay so
let's look at this um uh information
first i got an email today from this fox
executive who said
david i joined today at joinpackman.com
i am a long time fox employee
i am in management at fox and i am
disgusted with the lies and
misinformation honestly hannity and
especially tucker deserve a kick in the
nuts you can say nuts that's that word
is allowed they make me sick the lies
that they are allowed to spread are sick
my political and philosophical views
pretty much match up with yours to a t
i've been listening for about three to
four months i used to not care about
politics but the trump years and the
pandemic made me a hardcore resister of
trump maga
racism lies covet and vaccine
misinformation of fox make me really
angry if i could afford to lose my job i
would say something but they pay me well
and the insurance is excellent
fox took covid seriously i worked on
site through the pandemic they paid all
my insurance premiums for the entire
pandemic see below please don't use my
name or email but feel free to contact
me if you wish i would call your
voicemail but i don't want anyone to
recognize my voice i will help if i can
i hate what fox has done and what they
have allowed to happen with tucker and
his patriot purge keep up the good work
and reach out to me if you like you can
talk about this if you like keep my name
out of it please also my email address
thanks for what you do keep up the fight
my friend regards uh see below fox
mentions insurance premiums below and
then a screenshot of the covid policy
this is very interesting this is someone
in fox management very very interesting
so check out some of the things that
they sent to me and these are
fascinating covid policy email
check this out
as we have said as we have through the
pandemic fox is following the guidance
and policies of the cdc as well as state
and local jurisdictions with mass
squaring and social distancing
requirements for fully vaccinated
individuals being lifted in nearly all
the areas where we operate fox has made
several important updates to our coveted
protocols as described below
for us to provide the most flexibility
to our employees we strongly encourage
everyone who has been fully vaccinated
to upload vaccination information into
workday instructions for how to do that
so they have a not only a vaccine a
protocol they have a vaccine reporting
protocol what about hipaa what about
hippo what about rhino and giraffe and
all of these things that are supposedly
being violated per the fox hosts as they
say on air well fox is doing it
fox is saying you got to upload the
proof my friends
fully vaxxed okay the new policies
effective immediately are as follows
fully vaccinated employees who have
uploaded status into workday
and it has been verified by hr are not
required to wear a mask or socially
distance when at work
employees are considered fully
vaccinated two weeks after their second
dose in a two dose series or two weeks
after a single dose however keep in mind
some work sites off party and third
parties have different requirements okay
fully vaccinated individuals who have
entered their vaccination info into
workday and it has been verified by hr
will be provided a fox clear pass oh my
god
is that is that like a star of david per
those
protesters who were putting the yellow
stars on them saying this is what it is
when you have to prove your status well
fox is doing it folks fox is doing it
um
you will have to um and it goes on to
say you have to do a screening process
each day that you go to work each day
you go to work
all right
unvaccinated employees or people who
simply have not provided their
vaccination info
are
going to
have to
continue
to complete the daily screening
note employees who may be fully
vaccinated but who have not entered
their info
will be considered
unvaccinated so you not only have to be
vaccinated but you have to prove your
vaccination which many of these
anti-requirement anti-mandate
anti-protocol people including on fox's
airwaves are against because it is
medical apartheid
it's uh okay you guys remember all the
things they said
here's another fascinating message this
was an email from the office of kevin
lord dear colleagues following our
request for employees to upload their
vaccination status in our secure system
we are pleased to share more than 90 of
our full-time employees reported they
are fully vaccinated wow it worked this
is important information as we continue
to implement phased return to office
timing and procedures
soon we will introduce another health
and safety measure
daily covered testing stricter than
biden's proposal for the small group of
employees not vaccinated or who have not
provided vaccination status
so again on air what biden is doing is
terrible behind the scenes
even stricter
even stricter here's one more which is
fascinating
on june 22nd 2021
fts issued an email for new covet
protocols as you know we have been
following the guidance of the cdc etc
however to optimize our efforts to
maintain a safe workplace we strongly
encourage everyone who has been fully
vaccinated to upload vaccine info to
workday attached our instructions
additionally you will need to provide hr
with a copy or photo
of your covid vaccination record card
for verification
fully vaccinated employees who enter the
information into workday will get a fox
clear pass permanent green screen which
you must show to security every day
unvaccinated employees or those who
don't get the fox clear pass must
continue to do a daily screening as
required
must continue to wear a face mask
and continue to social distance
as an employer
fox news is taking this very seriously
you wouldn't know it from watching the
segment on air in the morning on fox and
friends
midday with people like bill hemmer and
others dana perino whoever
at night watching laura ingram and
tucker and hannity
but behind the scenes
it is one of the strictest policies
we've seen thank you to that fox news
management individual who has
leaked these documents to us
we're going to go out of our way to
protect their privacy but understand
that what you were seeing on air does
not even come close to matching what's
happening behind the scenes find me on
twitter at dpakman we're going to take a
quick break and be back right after this
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but i know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to 200 off your order and you'll get two
super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video in the united states we have
due process we are innocent until proven
guilty that is a good thing that is not
something i would ever seek to change or
violate or argue against
but as a program that is just based on
my opinion on things
sometimes i give you my opinion of
people's behavior and sometimes people's
behavior is not indicative of them being
innocent now courts adjudicate guilt
versus lack of guilt they don't
adjudicate innocence
and that is the standard that applies in
courts
donald trump's behavior
continues colloquially without violating
anyone's due process without saying
trump should be charged or convicted of
any crime just observing his behavior as
a human it is not the behavior of an
innocent person and we are now learning
about donald trump's latest another
attempt the latest attempt to block
january 6th investigators from getting
access to information about what the
hell he was up to in the days leading up
to and during the trump riots there is a
very interesting politico article
and even actually the article is called
trump makes and loses overnight bid to
block january 6 investigators ron
phillipkowski who's doing a great job
covering this stuff tweeted this morning
in an odd move late last night trump
filed an emergency motion to block
documents from the national archives
from being turned over to congressional
investigators this friday odd because
the judge hasn't even ruled yet on his
previous objection
this is not
the behavior of an innocent person or
someone with nothing to hide going to
the politico article
if you blinked you missed it
former president trump filed an
emergency request to a federal judge
late monday night last night to prevent
the national archives from sending
sensitive records to the january 6th
committee investigators by friday and
just after midnight judge tanya chutkin
rejected it contending the request
itself was legally defective and
premature
not shocking
after the four years we had of trump's
uh uh peop the people around trump
making uh invalid legal arguments in
various courts that it is continuing the
unusual exchange happened in a span of
two hours and it came as chutkan is
already considering an earlier request
by trump to prevent congress from
peering into his white house's records
about his attempt to overturn the 2020
election trump sued to block the
archives from turning the records over
last month after joe biden declined to
assert executive privilege on his behalf
we covered that at the time the archives
indicate it would turn the papers over
to lawmakers by friday unless a court
intervened
chuck and heard arguments in the suit
last week promised to rule quickly on
the initial emergency request from trump
she seemed inclined to reject it
questioning the legal basis for a former
president to claim executive privilege
over records when the sitting president
and congress disagree the archives
indicated trump is seeking to block at
least 750 pages out of an initial 1500
unearthed in response to the january 6th
committee's request for records about
trump's attempt to overturn the election
many of the papers are called from the
files of senior trump aides like mark
meadows stephen miller and patrick
philbin they also include this is
important call and visitor logs who was
trump speaking to in the days leading up
to leaving office and leading up to the
trump riots and who was visiting trump
at the white house
in those same important days
trump's attorney jesse binnell issued
his second request monday night asking
chutkin to approve an administrative
stay of her own ruling even before she
issued it that way bennell argued trump
would have a chance to appeal her
decision before the archives began
delivering hundreds of pages to
congressional investigators so again
trump hasn't been charged with any
crimes i'm not saying he should be i'm
not saying that any any jury should rule
any way every time we do this i get
emails from right winger saying david
don't you believe in due process don't
you believe until innocent until proven
guilty i not only do i believe in those
things my belief belief in those things
is irrelevant to the fact that that is
the system we have in the justice system
this is not the justice system here
this is not about guilt or innocence
this is about donald trump's attempt to
block records from being given to the
committee and it is not colloquially
speaking my opinion and that of many in
my audience from the emails i'm getting
this is not the behavior of an innocent
person this is not the behavior of
someone with nothing to hide so we are
going to continue to follow this and we
will see
if and when these documents ultimately
get to the january 6th commission what
they uncover now as a reminder much like
with the the debate about trump's tax
records and the legal wrangling around
it this is about the release of these
documents to the january 6th committee
it is not about their public release so
it's not like if the judge says we're
not stopping it we get access to these
documents we might if they leak or are
subsequently released but it is at least
in the immediate just about releasing
these documents to those investigating
the january 6 riots just a reminder they
might leak i would not encourage that
leaking but if they leaked i would
certainly look at them let's put it that
way
we have new reporting from abc's
jonathan carl
which reveals
that donald trump actually threatened
the republican party with leaving the
republican party
on january 20th as he was flying out on
air force one for the last time that
these are unbelievable details from
jonathan carl in his new book
this is a book in which uh the book is
called betrayal the final act of the
trump show
and in the book
carl reports
that trump went to the gop chairwoman
the chairwoman of the republican party
and said on january 20th i'm leaving the
party and i'm creating my own party and
i don't care if this destroys
the republican party now trump hasn't
done that and the book recounts that
trump ultimately backed down but only
when republican leaders threatened trump
with what really
hurts him which is his finances that's
really ultimately what donald trump
cares about now the details of the
incident are unbelievable
this reportedly took place on january
20th up on air force one as donald trump
was quite literally taking his final
flight out as president of the united
states here's a quote from jonathan
carl's book
rnc chairwoman ronna mcdaniel called to
wish him farewell it was a very
unpleasant conversation donald trump was
in no mood for small talk or nostalgic
nostalgic goodbyes carl writes he got
right to the point he told her he was
leaving the republican party and would
be creating his own political party the
president's son donald trump jr was also
on the phone the younger trump had been
relentlessly denigrating the republican
national committee for being
insufficiently loyal to trump in fact at
the january 6 rally before the capital
riot the younger trump all but declared
that the old republican party didn't
exist anymore
it then got
very real with the following exchange
quote i'm done trump told mcdaniel i'm
starting my own party
you cannot do that mcdaniel told trump
if you do we will lose forever to which
trump responded exactly you lose forever
without me
i don't care this is what republicans
deserve for not sticking up for me
mcdaniel said this isn't what the people
who depended on you deserve the people
who believed in you you'll ruin your
legacy you'll be done
but trump said he didn't care
call carl writes
so
first of all
not law the the party wasn't loyal to me
trump says what he means by that is
they didn't do enough as he sees it to
steal an election that he lost back they
didn't they didn't execute the coup that
donald trump wanted executed
uh joe biden won
and the republican party as trump sees
it should have figured out a way
to give him another four years in the
white house anyway so that's what that
issue here which is
it's mind-blowingly childish
so a few different things number one
this is completely on brand for donald
trump
there's nothing surprising that this is
trump is a if i've got to leave the
sandbox i'm going to poop in it so that
nobody else can play in it i'm going to
shut the whole thing down
number two it confirms that donald trump
doesn't care about people who he sees as
no longer being useful to him so this
applied to his supporters
this applied to donors who he fleeced
claiming the money's going to go to
recounts and ardets and all these
different things
and it applies to elected officials as
well
if you're not going to or you're going
to refuse to or whatever to steal the
election for me you're not no longer
useful to me either neither is the party
so i'll just leave and number three it
also confirms that republicans are
essentially trump's accomplices
they may privately believe whatever
about donald trump and some of them
obviously don't like trump some we know
and some
haven't said it publicly but it makes
sense that some of them don't like trump
but
they begged him to stay rather than
leave and they recognize the damage that
trump could do i don't think ronald
mcdaniel is wrong if trump did start his
own party at least in 22 and 24
he could single-handedly lead to
republicans losing everything and losing
badly by siphoning off a portion of the
of the republican electorate creating
three three-way races which democrats
unilaterally win
um and then number four it also confirms
that trump in the future is going to do
what he sees is best for himself it
might be bad for the republican party
trump was not a republican much of his
life he concocted this whole republican
persona in order to run and we we've
talked about that before
and trump is going to continue doing
what's best for him and it might
conflict with what's best for the
republican party if trump might do
something next year or the year after
that would be bad for the republican
party not only should we let him do it
we should encourage him to do it um if
he only if if he followed through with
this threat the left would be in a far
better position going into 22 and 24. um
but
uh trump did not ultimately leave the
republican party because at the end of
the day he accepted and recognized and
agreed that it would be bad for him
financially to do that trump has never
really been a republican trump serves
his interests he has his own agenda
that's all he cares about and right now
he seems to be trying to keep his
stranglehold on the republican party
because he knows that he needs their
money if he wants to run in 24
and at least for now
he has more to gain by remaining a power
player in the republican party than by
abandoning it because remember if trump
abandons the republican party and starts
his own it's bad for republicans but
it's also probably a losing bet for
trump it's really best for democrats and
the left to the extent that the left is
existing within the democratic party um
as soon as and if it becomes clear to
trump
that it would be good for him to do that
financially and from a pr standpoint he
will do it the guy doesn't care and just
incredible incredible stories here in
jonathan carl's forthcoming book which i
think i think might be out next week or
the week after
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram which you can find
at davidpakmanshow on instagram you can
also find me on instagram at
david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program chris had naggy the founder and
ceo of social engineer llc and also an
adjunct professor of social engineering
for the university of arizona also
author of the book human hacking when
friends influence people and leave them
better off for having met you chris
always great to talk to you oh great to
talk to you too again david so many
might recognize when friends and
influence people to reference reference
to the great uh dale carnegie book uh
sort of really should be it's important
reading i feel like for for everybody it
contains a lot of interesting
information
what is the connection between the title
of your book and the dale carnegie book
so i i love that book right i really do
and it and like you said i think it
should be required reading in school
because it has so many great principles
in it but if some of us don't know it
was written in in the 1930s right so
it's a it's a really old book and i i
it's just like an
a homage to carnegie and saying hey i i
have some new principles that we can use
some new techniques for the modern era
that are all taken from from my work as
a social engineer and uh let's see how
we could keep that same principle here
being kind to people really getting to
know them learning how to communicate
but bring it to the 21st century so it's
really an ode to him and in the past you
and i have talked about different ways
in which social engineering can be used
i guess i would say for bad in the sense
of used to scam people
use to defeat physical security and you
work in testing physical security and
cyber security at different companies
etc um but there's also sort of like
another side to social engineering which
is simply like better understanding how
to get along with people how to relate
to people etc there's a totally there's
a flip side to it there is and and it
was only after i was doing that part the
security part for about a decade that i
said i wonder what happens if i just use
this same thing i did to break in this
building but do it when i'm at the
checkout line or if i'm just waiting for
coffee or i'm
at a store and somebody's angry can i
defuse that situation and i just started
trying these things little by little and
without manipulating people without
having to force someone into doing
something they didn't want to do i found
that you can communicate with people and
get almost anything you want just by
being nice kind and empathetic and
that's how this book came about i i've
said to people on on my show before and
in other circumstances that one of the
experiences
that most sort of leveled up my ability
to build rapport and relate to people
was working in sales at the now defunct
electronics chain circuit city where i
started when i was 16 years old then you
had all sorts of different people coming
in many already angry because of some
bad experience they had you know um uh
people who wanna they don't know whether
you can actually help them figure out
what laptop to buy for their kid or
whatever the case may be
it's an incredibly valuable skill to
have to know how to very quickly relate
to people and build rapport can you talk
about sort of some of the principles and
again we're not talking about
manipulating people we're just talking
about relating to people yeah and i i
think that's a really important point
that last point you brought up because
that's why at the very end of that title
i put and leave them feeling better for
having met you right because the the
mission is yeah you can go out and use
these principles for bad you can't and
you can manipulate people you can get
them to do things they don't want to do
but if you leave that one thought in
your head which is anything i do right
now i'm going to make sure you feel
better when we're done interacting that
you're going to go man that was a great
conversation i like that guy right if i
do that then i'm not going to manipulate
you right so let's just think of robert
cialdini's principles of influence we
could take one right let's use uh liking
viking is an easy one right so he makes
this statement that people like people
who are like them
and people like people who like them so
i can fake it and i can be all nice to
you and smiley but then later on you
hear me go oh man i really hate that guy
and now you feel bad you don't feel good
so then you're like oh he manipulated me
he got me to do something he didn't even
like me that that's not cool or i can
learn to say i'm going to pick something
out about this person i don't know and
i'm going to be interested in them and i
really am and i'm going to want to know
more about you and you're going to tell
me about that now later on you're going
to think man i met this great guy at
that coffee shop and we had an amazing
conversation for complete strangers
and it's that simple where you could use
that same principle you can manipulate
someone or you can change the way you
communicate and you can influence
someone and and really communicate in a
more holistic way building rapport and
making friends that may be short-term or
long-term but either way you you walk
away with a an amazing interaction with
a complete stranger now i think that
there are many i know in my audience but
out there in the general public who they
hear this conversation or they read dale
carnegie's book and they say
i'm an introvert this stuff doesn't work
for me this is horrifying this actually
this is the these are the last types of
things that i want to be doing and we do
see actually that in ceos for example
introversion is underrepresented
relative to the general population
there's a question right as to
sort of that
what about that what about the fact that
for a lot of people this entire way of
thinking about relating to others is is
just very unappetizing yeah that's
that's an awesome question because my
ceo at social engineer he is a massive
introvert and uh we always talk about
this because he's he's one of the
leading social engineers and you know he
goes and breaks in the buildings
communicates with people does all this
stuff
we always talk about okay how do you do
this how do you get there so the first
step is you have to as an introvert you
have to have a desire to change
right and you really do it has to be
from you it can't be because i tell you
to do it or you know they hear something
on a show that has to be like okay look
i i just want to try something new
because it's that desire to step out of
your comfort zone that is the first step
now where i see a lot of people who are
introverts fail is they hear this
conversation they go okay i'm gonna go
out and do it and they pick the whole
thing right i'm gonna go out and do this
whole thing and now it's scary maybe
they fail a little and then they go i
knew i couldn't do it don't do that pick
one thing say hey today when i go into
starbucks i'm gonna get one person's
first name that's it start small so i'm
gonna get one person's first name so now
i'm standing in line and you're in front
of me and i'm an introvert and i go hey
is that the new iphone you know i was
thinking of upgrading do you like that
you know is it good do you have any
problems with it and they'll talk your
ear off and then you go man thanks hey
i'm chris you shake my hand go i am dave
great now we could part ways and i
accomplished that one goal i asked you a
question i got your first name now next
time say now i'm going to get someone's
full name right and you give yourself
little incremental steps instead of
saying i'm going to go do this whole
thing and what you'll find is eventually
it will get easier and easier but if
you're not naturally a person who likes
to just go out and talk to strangers
then don't throw yourself in the deep
end right you start swimming you stay
where you can stand still so now do it
little the flip side of this and again
in thinking about your expertise in
phishing and wishing and you know all
these different things is
sometimes um the reason people get
sucked into scams
is because the person who's scamming
them has exactly the skills that you're
talking about right they're they're hey
that was a great experience i ended up
feeling good about that i like this
person they seem trustworthy so what
about the other side which is being
equipped to protect yourself from people
who may do exactly the things you're
saying but with with uh
with subterfuge so to speak no that's
that's an awesome question so here's
what i tell people because
uh sometimes i'll hear people give
suggestions for protection but they they
make us not human
and we can't do that we can't i mean
first of all we can't uh you can't
control your emotional output it's
you're you're a person so if if you feel
fear or if you feel happy or if you see
someone that you think is attractive
your body is going to react in a way and
you're not going to be able to control
it right right so what i tell people is
to if you could stay self-aware in a
conversation
and when i start to feel emotional about
something whatever that emotion is happy
fear sadness whatever to analyze quickly
is what i'm being asked to do next
dangerous or not
right so let's say i'm the introvert
standing in line with my brand new
iphone yeah you come up behind me and
you're the introvert that's going to
have a talk with me
and you say hey is that the brand new
iphone like i was thinking of upgrading
and i don't really want to talk to you
but i'm now self-aware and i go why
would he ask me that and but you said oh
he's going to try to upgrade okay well
what you're asking me is not anything
dangerous so i go yeah this is the new
iphone
and now if you said hey can i hold it
can i see it
now i don't know i feel a little weird
why is a stranger asking me to hand you
my phone so i'm like well i don't really
feel comfortable with that with covid
and everything sorry but you know i'll
show it to you
now i i could be self-aware with that
and say you know i don't feel
comfortable with that level of
interaction but you're just asking me
about my phone you're not asking me for
my phone number or credit cards or
anything then i can continue that
conversation so it's a matter of staying
self-aware
during the conversation to make sure you
don't give anything out that could put
you in danger and that's exactly i i
feel like and i'm curious to see what
you think that's exactly what
the this good scammer social engine
engineer is probably good at which is
maybe even delaying the asks that raise
red flags until enough trust has been
built where the mark would say i don't
know it's been an hour it i've known
this person for a month and it's all
been fine so and and maybe that's where
the difficulty comes with the more
sophisticated scams
true and you know i just read a story um
it was about a couple months ago this
poor widowed woman lost 114 thousand
dollars in a romance scam it didn't
happen overnight you know they were
quote unquote dating online and this guy
took her for a couple thousand five
thousand and ten thousand and
incrementally got more and more and more
uh a year or so into it she's out 114
thousand dollars this poor woman um yeah
so you're right it's it's they they
build the relationship because the
principle of influence is that we talk
about before from childini or rapport um
you will give more to someone who you
trust more right so they can't come up
to you and say hey dave give me 114 k
and you're like heck no man but if all
of a sudden we're best friends you know
we're we're we're like blood brothers
and you trust me with everything well
maybe maybe now you would part with that
if i really need it and you have it so
they they wait to build that
relationship to do the ask hey to talk
about something from the last sort of
year and a half related to all of this
what are we seeing in terms of uh
scamming and fishing etc related to
kovit i mean the one thing i've seen is
calls sort of like the social security
calls but related to the covet stimulus
we were seeing that for a little while
but that's
it's sort of just a version of something
we've seen before what else are we
seeing so
because
this is such a global thing
normally when we see some kind of
catastrophe it's very localized like a
you know a flood in louisiana or the
earthquake in haiti or something like
that where you go okay this is localized
and then they attack that group of
people
this is not this is global so what we're
seeing is that these attacks are
happening all over to everyone and
they're very fear-based so see you know
click here to download this app to see
who has covet in your area that's a big
one they want to take over your phone uh
emails coming from your work saying hey
we need you to install this program to
work from home
right then you like the phone calls
where this is a huge thing think about
it people working in the office
now you got mom dad and two kids all
trying to find a place at home to work
so you're working from your bedroom your
kitchen table somewhere else and you're
working more than you ever were before
now you get a call someone that says
they're from i.t hey listen we got to
put a patch on your machine so you can
connect to the vpns while you're you
know at home and people will install
programs and this is how we're seeing
major breaches occur phone email and sms
have gone through the roof and now you
add to that that verizon t-mobile and
att have all been breached in the last
12 months your phone number is out there
my phone number's out there this is why
we're seeing an increase in phone calls
and text messages all over is there any
um are are there blanket recommendations
that
take people out of having to make sort
of like one-on-one decisions as
frequently like for example i no longer
pick up my phone at all unless i know
exactly who's calling me and it's for a
bunch of different reasons including
that people who don't like me have found
my phone number yeah but but also
because overwhelmingly if i don't
recognize the number if it's a real call
they're going to leave a voicemail yes
and if it's not i never hear back so
like that would be one thing that i do
are there other blanket things everybody
can just make regular practices yeah uh
these will seem a little technical but i
will say them just because i think
that's a very important topic first is i
encourage everyone to use a password
manager
because the issue with the phone calls
and stuff is eventually we're going to
answer a call or we may fall for
something
but if we use a password manager then we
don't have the same password on every
website yeah and they're easy to change
and control but even if you do that the
next thing is vitally important and
that's to use multi-factor
authentication on everything that allows
you and if you have a choice don't use
the one that sends you a text message
using the one that lets you use an app
you know like duo or authy or microsoft
authenticate or something like that
because that they need to have access to
your physical phone in order to get that
and if they have that you already have
bigger problems right so those two
things alone and there's a ton of others
but those two things alone could save so
many people um and then the third thing
i'll say and this is something that we
can do for free in america um which is
you could put a freeze on your credit
with all three major credit bureaus
right and you can do that you don't have
to pay a service it's easy it takes five
minutes and you can unfreeze it in five
minutes and i suggest everyone do that
because if you have a password manager
multi-factor authentication and your
your account is locked
people even if they steal your data
they're not going to be able to use it
so that keeps you from having to worry
boy did i just mess up did i give
someone the wrong thing and and it can
keep you relative as nothing will keep
you hacker proof but it could keep you
relatively safe now in terms of just the
incoming phone calls
is there
sometimes you get legit phone calls
because there really has been you know
your credit card calls because there's a
charge they want to confirm or
i don't know if banks really call people
frequently my bank doesn't call me but
i'm guessing banks make phone calls
sometimes for real
so is there some overarching principle
that can be applied to any incoming
phone call to prevent falling even if
it's one out of a thousand that you fall
for yeah um so i i do exactly what you
said which is i let them go to voicemail
even if it looks legit or if i do pick
it up and let's just say it's my bank
and they go hey this is your bank we
have some weird charges we need to
verify yeah i say hey i can't talk right
now i'll call you back i do not call the
number on the phone i take my card out
of my wallet i call the toll-free number
and i say hey someone just called me
from the bank saying there are some
weird charges i need to verify right
because i know that i'm talking to the
real bank because i called you but when
you call me i don't know and if they
just start trying to verify information
heck man with some of these breaches
they have all of that so they can sound
super legit sure you know so i just you
and don't ever call a number they give
you just yesterday i had a a friend of
mine who got a call someone saying
they're from amazon and they were
helping them try to complete a purchase
on the account and they were they needed
them to install a program they didn't
fall for it but they gave him a number
and he called the number back and
someone picked up oh amazon how can we
help you right so they even have people
answering the phone
with the you know the numbers that
they're giving out so you can't trust it
if they give it to you but if you call a
legitimate number then you can trust it
another one i've seen gotten recently is
i'll get an email saying
hey um we just charged you 40 bucks
for the something you ordered and of
course you go i didn't order that i
gotta go and get a refund so then you
look at the info on the email and of
course if you called my guesses they
would say oh yeah what was the credit
card number you put it or and and then
you're off to the races yeah and and if
you think about that sounds so
legitimate right because if i call in to
an actual vendor like if i call my bank
right now they're going to say please
verify the account you're calling about
right they're not going to give me the
account
they're going to ask me to verify it so
i'm going to legitimately give them my
account number sure which could be my
credit card so if i call what i think is
my bank and they go hey to look you up
we need to verify your identity i need
your full name your account number your
social security that sounds all
legitimate right so people will give it
over and what they don't know is that if
you didn't call if you didn't initiate
that call there's no way for you to
verify that you're speaking to the
actual company the actual person right
right so i always say the best practices
you have to initiate the call um you
know unless there's some solid proof
like you know you're standing you're
you're on the phone and they're
verifying with you enough that you feel
comfortable with that or they're not
asking you for personal details i still
really just i'd rather just pick up the
phone and call them back agreed agreed
we've been speaking with chris had naggy
founder and ceo of social engineer llc
the book is human hacking when friends
influence people and leave them better
off for having met you chris always
appreciate your time thanks david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right i
don't know if we call this an exercise
in irony or an exercise in i mean listen
i don't know maybe if you believe in
karma and these types of things maybe
that's the way you interpret this but a
republican is going to be unable to
attend
an anti-vaccine rally because he now has
covid and is treating covid with all
sorts of unproven
uh treatments it's another one of these
stories uh this is being reported in the
new york daily news uh a republican
lawmaker in north dakota will miss his
monday rally opposing vaccine mandates
because he has covered instead
representative jeff hoverson says he
will stay home and take a cocktail of
medications including the unproven
anti-parasite drug ivermectin
and the malaria remedy
hydroxychloroquine
that's uh jeff hoverson showing a
picture of him now
covid is real and like a really bad flu
he wrote on facebook i am currently
quarantining and each day is getting
better hoverson claims that his home
remedy which is popular with right-wing
pundits a lot of right-wing pundits now
give medical advice it's interesting
should be more widely used by the public
he noted noted he's not hospitalized and
he's on the mend he posted uh to
facebook thank you brave soul for
getting me
ivermectin which now with covid i am
able to stay out of the hospital covet
is real and like a really bad flu
quarantining and each day is getting
better ivermectin hydroxychloric
vitamins etc according to hundreds upon
hung grids of medical experts including
in north dakota should be our early
ambulatory care upon diagnosis give the
kids call and tell the state health
department to stop misleading the public
about these available treatments look
for yourselves take your pick of experts
lists a number of people
why is north dakota providing cover for
pharmaceuticals we should be keeping
people out of the hospital it may not
surprise you that this lawmaker is also
a pastor he told the associated press he
tested positive last week for
coronavirus he said three of his teenage
children will go to the anti-vaccine
rally he is a father of six hoverson has
battled mass mandates was barred from
boarding a flight with his wife
late last month because of an issue with
a pat down and said his wife he and his
wife were traveling for their
anniversary imagine um imagine for a
moment
in the future explaining to people
you know we had this pandemic
and millions died millions globally died
but then we got a vaccine
and then
there was a rally there was a rally
about the vaccine oh and the rally was
for people to get vaccinated right no
no the rally was against vaccination
what
imagine explaining it to a kid today
imagine saying to you know little sophie
or
little mordechai
dad
they're they're protesting
four vaccines right no they're not but
dad don't they want everybody to get
vaccinated so that we end the pandemic
no no no no little sophie they want
people
not to get the vaccine what
what it's a very very ugly episode in
american history and uh this here's one
guy who would have been at the protest
at the rally
but he's home with covid uh so he's not
going to be able to do it
all right um something something really
really bad for our show happened
yesterday as many of you know we have
been covering
every day of the kyle rittenhouse trial
in kenosha wisconsin
and these are long days we've been doing
the show and streaming close to the full
proceedings in court in kenosha i think
it's an important case i think it's an
interesting case uh somewhere between a
hundred thousand and 150 000 different
people each day are checking out our
coverage which has been on youtube
twitch and facebook we have been banned
by twitch for 30 days and we have been
banned by twitch for 30 days for showing
something which other channels also
showed including right-wing channels
which i'm not going to name because this
isn't about getting other people in
trouble
and uh
that something is that yesterday during
the proceedings during the testimony of
an individual named gage gross kreutz
an exhibit was put up by the prosecution
which was about eight or ten seconds of
video of gross kreutz after being shot
in the bicep and his bicep is bloody it
is gory and it was about eight or ten
seconds of that
we believe because of immediate
reporting by what we call antagonist
watchers that watch my stream to twitch
within about a minute or two our account
was suspended for 30 days
now the reason i say it was probably
because of people immediately reporting
us
we have a you know we have close to 100
000 followers on twitch i don't or we
did
i don't think twitch is watching our
stream
and the fact that it happened so quickly
and that other channels including
right-wing channels who showed the same
video have not been banned
suggests to me that was the reason now
this is i'm not gonna exaggerate but i'm
not gonna downplay it this is really bad
for us we've spent basically two plus
years since august of 2019 building our
following on twitch in my my
model of diversifying revenue streams
because we've seen youtube will take
away you know that who giveth sometimes
taketh away we've lost all of our
youtube revenue for periods of a couple
months we've had issues with facebook et
cetera um close to 100 000 followers we
had a thousand paid members on twitch
because we are now suspended for a month
none of those thousand paid
subscriptions will renew for us a
thousand paid members is a lot
um what am i doing to try to fix this
first of all let me say
i realize that
those eight to ten seconds
are against twitch's guidelines on gore
and playing violent videos etc
we appealed the decision and said we are
not doing a stream of gore we are not
showing
you know these kind of violence porn
videos we're showing a trial of of
newsworthy um significance
we're 40 hours into this trial and there
were eight seconds of a gory video it is
not our intent to broadcast gore
you know there are video games with dogs
being cut in half with chainsaws which
are allowed now i get video games are
different it's not real i i would also
argue that it's gratuitous and not
newsworthy in video games and i i think
it should be allowed to be clear i'm not
attacking video games i want to be
really really clear about that uh but
this is this is an important trial um we
should be allowed to show it and if
you're going to ban us for it you really
have to ban everybody and twitch has not
applied that even-handedly
um so we've appealed this to twitch
multiple times on different grounds
we've not heard back
i don't know whether
that's likely to go anywhere
but this really isn't good now i do want
to address there are people writing in
and saying david you've been arguing in
favor of platforms being allowed to do
this these are their terms of service
and they're enforcing them i'm not
making any legal issue here i i
i stan this is not a double standard i
stand by that twitch is allowed to have
terms of service and to enforce them
facebook is allowed to have terms of
service and to enforce them
i just disagree with the enforcement i'm
not going out and saying
this should be against the law we've got
to regulate twitch we've got to take
away their power i just think that they
should reconsider how they enforce this
on our channel because it's both
counterproductive to public education
about an important trial
and our intent is not to be showing
gory video after gory video it was eight
seconds
out of 40 hours that we have streamed of
this so
for the people emailing me saying this
is what you get david for saying they
should be able to enforce terms of
service no they should
i'm just making the argument in my
appeal that this was not the right
decision with regard to my channel if
they say it was the right decision i'm
not going to say they should be sued
i just disagree with the decision that
they made so in the interim i would like
it if people decided to grab a
membership on my website these thousand
paid members we lost on twitch
it's it's really a big hit it really is
a big hit um so i would love it if you
came over to join pacman.com
grabbed a membership there
and i'm gonna keep people posted as to
what is going on one last thing
i would love it if you respectfully
contacted twitch and said something
along the lines of please unsuspend
david pakman
his coverage of the trial is
a public service or whatever
uh be polite etc i can't give you an
email for who to contact i've been told
that in the past when people have said
email this this email address at twitch
twitch considers that doxing because i
the person gave out an email so i'm not
going to tell you how to contact twitch
figure it out on your own how to contact
twitch it's not that difficult and maybe
lobby for our uh on suspension i would
really appreciate that i don't know what
else we can do
we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 david p i want to be clear this is
satire this is not really anti-vaxx
content but here is a caller
telling me about some really weird
vaccine side effects that he got this is
funny
hi dave i'm just watching your episode
about the unhinged anti-vaxxed
woman you know at the school board and
her anti-semitic rant and i just want to
go on record as saying i've had both the
vaccine shots both of pfizer
uh early this summer and i'm feeling
great
except maybe for picking up telepathic
messages from the dark gods cthulhu from
the ghost of hp lovecraft
that doesn't doesn't matter i just put
some tinfoil in my hat and i'm fine to
go exactly so just let everybody know
there's no problem with the facts being
it's working good
at least it is according to the ghost of
hp lovecraft right all right very good
yeah i'm actually i'm gonna be getting
my third dose um scheduled for later
this week i will report to you what
symptoms i have you know i it did happen
that when i got my second dose
um i did kind of trip on a curb
and stub my toe on the way out
um and so that i don't know if i'm
supposed to report that in the vares
system but it did take a couple days to
heal and it sort of like chipped a
little bit of my toenail okay we've got
a great bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about the right wing
hysteria over big bird and getting
vaccinated it's crazy we will also talk
about the supreme court which will hear
arguments on the fbi's surveillance of
mosques
this is still a story and we will talk
about philadelphia's ban on low-level
traffic stops what does that mean what
qualifies as low-level all of those
stories and much more on today's bonus
show sign up and get instant access at
joinpackman.com
[Music]
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors if you're looking
for a mattress go with helix sleep their
two-minute sleep quiz will tell you
which mattress is perfect for you you'll
get up to 200 off and two free pillows
at helixsleep.com
pacman